hey Addison and Zed it seems like things
are going pretty good in Seabrook the
zombies have been accepted by everyone
Addison you're on the cheer team and the
two of you can finally be together
without hiding it but we heard there's a
new problem in Seabrook and it's going
to cause a lot of issues we really hope
the two of you are strong enough to face
the new crew in town
Disney Channel is starting to drop a few
clues about zombies too and we are
pumped find out everything we currently
know about the sequel to hit the Disney
Channel original movie keeping the peace
things are going pretty well in Seabrook
when zombies 2 starts we aren't sure
exactly how much time has passed between
the first and second movies but from
what we know the zombies seem to be
pretty well integrated into Seabrook
society a lot of the zombie bigotry has
moved on and everyone seems to be
getting along that is until a new group
arrives in town to upset the balance
we're glad the zombies are finally
getting the chance to be part of
Seabrook the cheer squad don't worry the
cheerleaders are back the first movie
was all about zombies versus
cheerleaders
Bucky led the high school's charge
against zombies but once Addison and the
lies I got on the team the cheerleaders
came around they aren't going anywhere
from the teaser that Disney Channel
dropped the cheerleaders are back in
action and they appear to be doing some
sort of obstacle course we can't wait to
find out what that's all about
[Music]
the lovebirds we are so glad to announce
that Addison and Zedd are back as the
stars of zombies to Meg Donnelly and
Milo Manheim have returned to reprise
their roles we love how these two played
a modern Romeo and Juliet with a happier
ending of course they really helps teach
audiences about acceptance and being
yourself these two lovebirds are still
together and going strong but some new
faces in Seabrook are going to put a
strain on their relationship we just
hope these two are strong enough to get
through it together
epic dance moves Disney Channel hasn't
released a full trailer yet they also
haven't leaked any of the musical
numbers but from the teaser trailer they
dropped in October we do know that the
dance numbers will be epic
they showed a few clips from dance
rehearsals with the cast there are
backflips and break dancing the dance
numbers in the first movie were so
amazing we have a feeling they'll be
even better in the new film the new guys
the first movie was all about zombies
and humans learning to get along and
coexist but zombies 2 introduces a whole
new group of supernatural beings that's
right there are werewolves in this new
movie and we are howling
Seabrook isn't a town that likes things
to be different we have a feeling that
things are going to be really hard for
these new werewolves we sure hope
they're nice to Addison and Zed but we
do know that the werewolf's will put a
strain on Addison and Ed's relationship
white hair don't care
see Brooke used to hate anything that
didn't conform Addison had to hide her
naturally white hair with a blonde wig
to fit in but after falling in love with
Zed she let her true colors show it's a
wig my real hair is Frankish and I can't
change it she took off her wig when she
told off the town for being so terrible
to zombies and from the clips Disney
Channel dropped it looks like she is
still rocking her white hair good for
her we are glad that Addison doesn't
have to hide any part of herself anymore
new characters there are at least three
new characters in zombies - Willa is
played by Chandler Kinney Windsor is
played by Ariel Martin and Pierce Joseph
plays Wyatt these three appeared to be
werewolves since all the zombies have
Z's in their names it's pretty clear
that the werewolves have a similar
naming system we don't know too much
about these characters they might be
siblings or just part of the same pack
we can't wait to find out
returning creators the first zombies was
so good it would be a shame if Disney
replaced any of the creators thankfully
we don't have to worry about that
director Paul Hoenn it's back to take
the reins and turn zombies to into just
as awesome of a production he is working
with the same writers David light and
dosa brah so we know that the story and
songs will be just as amazing as the
first movie hero the massive surprise
alright I guess you're just gonna have
to wait for the movie then guess who's
back there might be some new faces in
Seabrook but there are also a lot of old
ones Lacey and Stacy the cheerleaders
are back Zed's little sister Zoe is also
returning Bonzo and Eliza are back
representing the zombie crew and Bucky
is returning to we just hope that Bucky
learned his lesson in the first movie we
wonder if he'll be a nicer more
accepting person this time and we also
hope that Zoe still has her dog release
deeds Disney Channel hasn't set an
actual release date for zombies - yes
but they have confirmed it will be out
in 2020 there's a pretty good chance
that it will come out in February it was
supposed to be the first Disney Channel
original movie of the new decade so it
has to come out pretty early plus Disney
Channel likes to release movie sequels
around the same time as the previous
ones the verse Dom bees came out in
mid-february but we did something even
better we brought everyone together it's
a safe bet that zombies 2 will be out
somewhere around then what are you most
excited to see in zombies 2 let us know
in the comments thanks for watching give
this video a big thumbs up and subscribe
to the things for more great content
we'll catch you next time